To do this with math, the main operation we need is multiplication.
There's a few key properties of multiplication that we'll take advantage of.
The first is that it's commutative.
That means that a times b is always equal to b times a.
This is true on integers.
It's also true using any modulus.
This property also holds for powers of powers.
That means for any integers, a to the b based to the c power,
well, that's equivalent to a to the b times a to the b times a to the b c times,
which is equivalent to a to the b times c.
I'm just adding powers when we multiply here,
which is also equivalent to a to the c times b.
We know that from the commutative property of multiplication,
which is also equivalent to a to the c to the b.
Using the same property here, a to the c, a to the c b times.
These things are all equivalent, and they're also equivalent
with modular multiplication as well.
That's the main property the Diffie-Hellman Key Exchange takes advantage of,
and I'm going to show you the protocol next, and then we'll talk about
why it's secure and some of the details in actually implementing it.